suppose i want to send funds from my
wallet
so here's an example a transaction that
i might want to issue
so in this case what i'm doing is here
my wallet has one eth as we said
and then what i want to do is i want to
send a transaction to this particular
ethereum address and the amount of money
i want to spend is send a 0.9 ether okay
so that's what i'm asking metamask to do
and the question is what happens once we
issue once we press the send button and
the funds actually are supposed to be
sent out what does the wallet actually
do
well what the wallet software will do it
was it will go ahead and create a
transaction and use in this case an
ethereum transaction um of the format
that we saw before basically it says
i want to send
0.9 ether from my address to the address
specified over here
and i'm going to sign this transaction
yeah it's going to use the secret
signing key that's stored on my client
to sign that transaction that authorizes
the transfer of the funds okay so
remember remember that the signature can
only be generated by someone who has a
secret key the signature itself is just
a 64 bytes uh string
okay so now that we have a valid
transaction with a valid signature the
wallet will go we'll go ahead and send
the transaction to the ethereum network
okay so metamask will basically talk to
the metamask back-end system the
back-end system will go ahead and and
and transmit this transaction to the
entire ethereum network
now uh what happens on the ethereum
network well basically a miner is going
to go and remember miners are the ones
who write data to the blockchain the
miner will validate the transaction is
valid in other words um there are at
least 0.9 ethers in the associated with
that address the signature is valid and
so on and so forth and if the
transaction is valid the miner will go
ahead and include the transaction inside
of one particular block
and then it will go ahead and broadcast
a block to the ethereum network
once the network accepts the block
basically the transaction the block is
added to the blockchain and the
transaction is recorded and can never be
removed yeah so the this transaction is
recorded on the blockchain there's now a
specific transaction says 0.9 eth was
transferred from this address to that
address um and as we said the
persistence property means that that
transaction can never be removed from
the blockchain
that's the idea okay so that's how we
use wallets to send funds from one
address to another
okay now the interesting thing is there
are lots of tools that will help you
look on the blockchain and see the
status of different addresses remember
everything on the blockchain is public
not only is it public it's replicated
across lots and lots and lots of
individuals
so
in particular we can look there's a tool
called etherscan and again i encourage
you to go and
just search for this tool it's a
beautiful website very very easy to use
and then you can explore different
addresses on the ethereum blockchain so
in this particular case we're looking at
this address
and you can see that currently this
address has this many ether associated
with it so 95 ether you know well ether
scan is kind enough to actually tell you
how much that's worth in dollars and it
tells you that that address actually
processed or rather
there were 35 000 transactions where
this address was involved okay so funds
being transferred to it and funds being
transferred from it all right so you can
see that exactly what transactions were
done and in particular if you look at
the transaction the 0.9 ether that we
sent on the previous slide
you can wait a few seconds and then
you'll see it on the on ether scan
you'll see that the transaction was
actually recorded on the blockchain
which meant that we actually sent 0.9
ether from our address to somebody
else's address yeah so this is this is
uh fairly easy to use i kind of
encourage you to go try uh play play
with it yourself just so that you see
that you're comfortable in sending you
can send one dollar
from one address to another so you can
see how this works
so now we understand how to send funds
from a particular address the question
is how did the funds get into that
address in the first place how did the
one ether get into our wallets to begin
with okay so how do we transfer funds
into our wallet well again we follow
three steps the first step is we go and
create an account with one of the um
crypto exchanges so there are lots and
lots and lots of crypto exchanges out
there um i wrote a couple of well-known
ones coinbase kraken bitfinex but there
are many many many uh crypto exchanges
out there
now what do exchanges do by the way it's
kind of interesting coinbase is is very
limited in the number of bitcoin in the
number of currencies that it will
actually uh um uh manipulate so for
example coinbase agrees to only purchase
bitcoin bitcoin cash uh ether or
litecoin uh coins for you they're very
restrictive in um who they can operate
with so they opera only operate with the
largest uh blockchains out there but
other exchanges will operate with with a
large number of blockchain so if you
want to buy
crypto assets outside of this set of
four you can go to other exchanges to do
it
so you open an account with one of those
exchanges step number two is you use
your fiat currency you know dollars yens
whatever
euros whatever fiat currency you have
you send that to the exchange and the
exchange buys funds on your
buys crypto assets on your behalf so it
will give you uh crypto assets in
exchange for the fiat currency and then
step number three is you can either keep
the currency you just bought
at the exchange or you can send
that currency to your own local wallet
yeah so
um
the wallet that we just saw before you
can basically have those funds
transferred to the address that you
created and then you know the secret key
like i said is held on your machine and
no one can take those funds away from
you unless you actually sign a
transaction using the secret key okay so
that's how you deposit funds into the
wallet so now we understand how funds
are deposited we understand how to send
funds to a different address
i should say by the way if you want to
convert cryptocurrencies back to fiat
currency you can use the exchange to do
that as well you would send funds uh you
would send the cryptocurrencies to an
address provided by the exchange and the
exchange will credit your accounts uh
with the corresponding amount of uh of
fiat currency so you can translate back
and forth you can send funds
between addresses you can even send
funds between
blockchains yeah they might be different
blockchains like you want to send funds
from the bitcoin blockchain to the
ethereum blockchain all that is
supported by all these by this ecosystem
that's evolved